john bail est ce vous êtes resté huit
ans sans faire de disque
est-ce que vous avez cru que c'était
fini que vous en feriez plus jamais je
n'ai pas désespérée nono déçu de temps
en temps mais mais c'est le question de
l'évolution musée
il ya beaucoup changé
c'était une question de chercher
exactement
pas vraiment on lui nie chercher
exactement quoi faire pour moi même
chose que je fais le mieux et parce que
je ne fais pas le pouvoir qu il ya des
gens qui s'est beaucoup mieux que moi
alors
il cherche du corps vous avez vu que ya
plus de maisons de disques voulait faire
du disque avec vous j'ai des problèmes
de voix aussi ça roule pour tous c'est
un choc pour tout le monde oui parce que
c'était pour moi quelque chose de
complètement naturel vu jamais
et avec un professeur de
chante alors l'âge de
35 quelque chose que nous avions
peut-être jeu je dois aller chercher et
j'ai trouvé un bon professeur
il rigole il est allégué ali nous
rigolons ensemble et c'est pour ça que
c'était possible pour moi de chercher
quoi faire de moi maintenant je répète
chaque matin alors dans trois tours ce
père de cinq filles et des morceaux de
vous bien sûr votre sur votre fils
s'appelle key
je vous donne du souci c'est le fils oh
oui sûrement
sinon il est faible et pilar le fait
qu'il est un peu il hervé robert howe il
est très très très beaux attraits parce
est très charmant
peut-être dans cinq ou six ans c'est un
juste retour des choses remarquer que ce
soir oui c'est l'enfant rebelle des
morceaux de dire strikes de youtou ya un
morceau de johnny clegg aussi et puis il
ya un morceau peter gabriel sting est ce
que vous croyez pas qu'aujourd'hui
finalement l'afrique du sud un peu
remplacer le vietnam dans la chanson
engagée
peut-être mais ça c'est parce que à mon
avis parce que c'est pour la génération
les jeunes maintenant ils cherchent
quelque chose qui cherche quelque chose
et ils ne sont pas prêts pour être
complètement engagé alors c'est leur
élévation contre
les chats apparaître sa céréales pour
c'est aussi l'autre autre côté du monde
alors c'est le premier pas pour moi je
pense et croit que les chansons peuvent
changer de monde
fc sion est prêt pour être engagé aussi
c'est uniquement des chansons non je
pense pas mais c'est un mythe que la
musique changé
c'est comme n'est pas ce que vous avez
un petit peu changé le monde où
seulement pu la changer
je sais pas c'est on change tout le
monde change pendant leur vie et
si on pense de faire les grands
changements dans le monde ça c'est pas
possible
mais s'ils ont vu le mot
souci comme ça est ce qu'on peut faire
comme ça voilà vous avez dit que vous
n'aimiez pas beaucoup les années 80
très dur bien sûr par rapport aux années
60 mais
voyez par les améliorations par exemple
bouby c'est plutôt la cote maintenant et
je vais le dire il va le new wave ça
commençait à changer du trouve plus la
musique a commencé à changer
je viens de commencer changé du tout il
ya un article de newsweek
maintenant c'est un retour aux racines
et
mais quand reagan et gorbatchev se
mettent d'accord sur des armements sou
de plus tôt
un peu c'est plus c'est pas grâce à greg
parce que moi je trouve qu'il n'a
absolument rien entre les oreilles mais
égaux retire les deux ont leurs raisons
pour avoir un semis mais bien si on peut
dit chris juste deux minutes diminuer un
peu les armements cette sas est un bon
signe ça c'est quelque chose à faire
mais c'est grâce à mon avis c'est grâce
et les gens qui quittent toujours à
penser de commencer les diminuer et
finalement des deux avec leurs raisons
règle parce qu'il veut il veut laisser
quelque chose de lui même un souvenir
bons souvenirs lui-même et gorzow parce
que il ya des cons problème dans l'ain
n soviétique mais il ya ce que les
élections américaines se présente comme
jesse jackson c'est quelqu'un que
cassidian est très intéressant il est le
seul qui est intéressant il y a des il
ya quelque chose de bonn sur du cacao il
est contre la peine de mort les sols ah
bon jesse aussi mais c'est vrai était la
fortune au monde alors cette année en
dehors de 10 200 lits bref un livre qui
s'appelle une voix pour chanter n'est
pas très tendre avec bob dylan c'était
juste été honnête
ah bon je vous dit que quand vous étiez
avec lui vous à cacher son aventure avec
avec sarah qui étaient c'est quelqu'un
qui a une mère est compliqué en faux
c'est pas très gentil quand bien avant
non pas que ça tout ça est vrai beaucoup
c'est vrai qu'il refusait de chanter
avec vous à la fin des concerts
[Musique]
moi à mon avis n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt sur ça mais sinon c'était une
grande gâchis c'était pas bien expliqué
pas des bombes communication et tout
alors mais c'est fini pas de problème en
face a étonné tout le monde quand même
de voir que john baez comprend pour une
sainte madone de ses comptes comme ça
brutalement et partisane
si on pense que je suis une scène ça
c'est leur problème
ouais y'a un truc est très drôle savait
que johnson l'acteur de miami vice
c'est vrai que j'avais dit bourrust pour
pondre envisagerait pas un viol
oui il est sexy et très swing puisque je
ne sais pas qui a beaucoup ici j'ai
écouté mais il est très sexe vous
raconter une histoire qui apporte votre
étonnant parfum qui est quand même un
peu sûr de lui et c'est votre aventure
homosexuelle avec kim
c'est la seule aventure homosexuelle oui
et à mon avis c'était un peu comme les
secours passaient dans la vidéo le plus
part des femmes est d'aider des jeunes
hommes il y a quelqu'un si vous
souhaitez un professeur quelque chose là
j'étais un an et 13 spéciales pour et
ses dix pérou a disparu après
s'est pas gêné revanche s'est pas
réalisé pour moi c'était réaliser c'est
une fois une fois puis après c'était toi
j'aurais quand même temps and on and on
sait pas oui oui c'était bon ça vous a
procuré du plaisir c'était ça vous a
procuré du plaisir oui vous l'avez
regretter cette histoire non jamais des
ingrédients king of all the battle of
doit parler de nos à un rôle du roi
hérode
j'avais des rêves ce que j'ai écrit dans
le livre d'avoir des enfants partout les
chiens et les enfants qui qui joue avec
des chiens les chats et c'est mon droit
aux cuisines et jamais non je n'aime pas
marcher pour de l'argent vous avez
trouvé le rythme oui à ces trois
histoires et vos idées
le penser certaines de nos idées ont
triomphé probablement non parce que je
suis addict et le de lost réalité
réalisation de la non-violence dans la
vie dans la vie politique sociale
culturelle et tout ça est dans ma vie la
violence est
venu peut-être depuis remplir de plus en
plus mais on dit nous qui pensent que
gandhi avait de vraies idées
révolutionnaires que la non violence
jusqu'à maintenant c'est vraiment pas un
grand succès mais il ya une seule chose
qui est pire - succès ça c'est
l'organisation
à la violence
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus